well in Mexico at least 39 people have
been killed after a fire swept through a
migration Detention Center the incident
happened in the northern city of Juarez
near the border with the United States
about 70 people are believed to have
been inside 28 of those killed were
Guatemalan Nationals Mexico's President
says the blaze broke out when migrants
and Asylum Seekers set fire to
mattresses after finding out they would
be deported some family members are
waiting for information about their
loved ones
they forget we're human we have feelings
but we're treated like dogs we're not
told about anything our relatives could
die and we'd never hear about it
life for us in Mexico City what's the
latest that we're hearing about this
moment
we'll start with what we know we can
confirm that at least 39 people have
died following that Blaze at a migrant
Detention Center in the city of ciudad
Juarez right on the Mexico U.S border
just across from the U.S city of El Paso
Texas 29 people who were injured
following that brace that Blaze were
taken to Area Medical Centers in ciudad
Juarez that's what we know there are
still plenty of unanswered questions as
to what were the circumstances exactly
that led to these men at this Detention
Center being unable to get free being
unable to escape before that fire
ultimately claimed uh their lives now we
have also heard confirmation from uh
immigration officials in Guatemala that
at least 28 of the 39 who were killed
are Guatemalan citizens
um again to those unanswered questions
the circumstances that led to
essentially what was a fire trap for
these migrants we did hear from Mexican
president Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
early on Tuesday during his daily
morning press conference where he says
that he believes that the fire may have
been started by the migrants themselves
who he says may have lit mattresses on
fire following a protest after they had
learned that they potentially would be
deported but again this is still
something that we're trying to get more
information on so hopefully we'll have
those details within the next uh within
the next broadcast Manuel I understand
that Juarez is just one of several
centers like that along the border
between Mexico and the U.S what are
conditions like there
right so as you mentioned this is not
the only city where we're seeing
overcrowded conditions at migrant
shelters that sort of pushing migrants
into uh taking these desperate
situations to either Rush The Border or
to or to hold protest uh we should
mention that you know riots are not that
uncommon we've seen riots that migrant
detention centers uh take place before
just last year there was one in the city
of Tijuana across from the U.S state of
California there was a riot at a migrant
Detention Center uh in the city of
tapachula along Mexico's border with
Guatemala nothing anywhere near as
dramatic as what we're seeing uh in
terms of images out of sudav Juarez we
should make note however that is is sort
of taking the brunt of these sort of
Migrant populations that we're seeing
and a lot of that has to do with
implementation of an app by U.S Customs
and Border officials an app called CBP
one that migrants have reportedly said
is slow is faulty that's a migrant
experts have said that is if anything
leading to a bottleneck effect of
migrants who are creating these
overcrowded conditions in cities like
ciudad Juarez but again this is
certainly one of the deadliest incidents
involving a migrant Detention Center in
recent memory and highlights one of the
many dangers that migrants face during
this dangerous journey across Mexico
ultimately leading them to the U.S
Southern border bringing us up to date
from Mexico City that's Manuel rapalo
Manuel thank you very much indeed